quel soulagement n'est ce pas parce que
les six derniers mois ont été éprouvants
pour cet athlète dont le plus grand rêve
est d'aller aux jeux olympiques de tokyo
cet été prévoyez les aux jeux olympiques
en tout cas je l'espère bien parce que
c'est un des espoirs canadiens en termes
de médailles
la décision de la fédération
internationale de canoë tomber le ce
matin la multiple championne et de
meddahi meddahi médaillés depuis des
années laurence vincent lapointe est
blanchi des accusations de dopage qui
pesait sur elle depuis le 13 ou de les
abaisser toute une histoire
écoutez c'est pas parce que je suis le
consolera vincent lapointe bonsoir pour
le dire d'abord félicitations de cette
victoire mais quand on est testé puis
quand on décèle une petite substance on
est condamnés en partant c'est le
fardeau de la preuve vous revient est ce
ce combat là vous avez mené depuis six
mois
oui il faudrait c'est très difficile
parce que automatiquement tout le monde
à ce que qu'on est coupable
surtout au niveau public
vu que je suis champion du fond du monde
plusieurs fois j'ai été un peu une
figure publique donc tout de suite le
monde on se sont fait une opinion dans
dix ans on gagne toujours c'est sur
quatre et chalmin el marsa dans
l'inconnu le phénomène aussi geneviève
jeanson qui avait nié cavani cavani puis
le dénouement était tout autre mais
qu'avez vous fait pour prouver votre
innocence
ça peut être simple on a fait beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d' analyse on a
analysé cette chose qui était dans mon
environnement directement des choses que
je soupçonnais avoirs qu'ils pourraient
être contaminés que je vais manger dans
la semaine d'avant
aussi j'ai vérifié avec tout le monde
que je côtoyais ce qu'il y avait
quelqu'un qui avait pris quoi que ce
soit parce que on sait jamais je peux
avoir bu dans le var de quelqu'un la
substance et le guide
quand troy lee landreau le gardien du
les gars drôle donc moi je connais fait
aucune mention peu je peux vous dire
qu'on fait des recherches après ça on se
demande d'où ça vient d'où ces produits
donc on a cherché ce j'ai fait tester
mes chers j'ai vérifié pour s'y voir
s'il y avait la présence de jean gandois
dormi dans mes cheveux j'ai passé un
polygraphe
on a aussi plus tard on a fait passer le
test pour les cheveux à mon ex conjoint
et finalement on a fait tester après
avoir eu le résultat de son produit et
tous les suppléments alimentaires les
vôtres comme les siens tout ça mais
comment êtes vous arrivé à cette idée
que ça pourrait dans les cheveux de
votre ex-conjoint en fait au départ ce
n'était pas nécessairement que je me
disais ça serait dans ses cheveux
ces jeux on se disait le moins d'enfants
j'ai évalué par tous qui étaient autour
de moi tout ce qui m'avait touché
directement tout le monde que je
côtoyais j'ai demandé est ce que vous
avez pris quelque chose ce que vous êtes
prenez de la mid caps y ont donc essayé
de ratisser large
puis après avoir évalué tout ce qui
était vraiment le plus proche de moi on
se dit c'est la personne qui a vu passer
plus de temps avec moi c'est lui
peut-être que lui aussi a été contaminé
en fait c'est à dire un peu sur la
nationale au début c'est de vérifier ce
que lui ont été contaminées si oui
peut-être coeur on note qu en commun
sauf que car ses revenus positifs sur
plusieurs mois
le conseil de l'espèce difficile
évidemment très très coûteux quelle a
été sa réaction la surprise
on s'entendait ni l'un ni l'autre à ce
que à ce que ce soit lui
certainement pas sauf que je peux vous
dire lui je pense pas qu ils savaient
que ce qui prenait contenait du liant
drôle je pense pas que il
il pensait que c'était lui qui avait du
stress en artif à bathurst pour
quelqu'un qui se reforment envie d'aller
dans les alpes et donc ça a dû
surprendre bien des gens mais il m'a
même assez à lausanne que sont faits les
l'était sous entendant lausanne ça a été
l'audience politesse ont été faits à
strasbourg en partie et aussi dans un
laboratoire aux états unis pour lier les
analyses des produits
mais tout ceci reste en suspens sera
pendant des mois comment l'avez-vous
ressenti comment on se sort de sol s'est
dit si c'est difficile parce que c'est
j'ai commencé par avoir un très très
gros bol j'ai été à terre pendant deux
mois c'était du sud de fonctionner au
quotidien
puis après ça j'ai eu une expérience qui
m'a vraiment beaucoup aidé à me rendre
compte que je pouvais passer autre je
pouvais continuer à m'entraîner
recommencé à m'entraîner
ça m'a aidé c'est le groupe b de 10 sur
10 ils m'ont invité à une retraite avec
d'autres athlètes qu'il discute avec les
autres je me suis rendu compte un
athlète c'est une personne normale mais
là c'est différent c'est que ça compte
c'est que il continue à s'entraîner même
quand les chances sont minimes de
pouvoir se classer quoi que ce soit ils
donnent tout ce qu'ils ont je me suis
dit bon si je tenais très rapidement si
je veux juste continuer à m'entraîner
parce que je suis très sévère c'est que
vous n'aviez pas accès à aucun
entraîneur de votre fédération vous
étiez littéralement une part hier
pendant ces mois là là oui je n'avais
pas le droit d'avoir de contact avec
quelqu'un qui est de la fédération mais
non seulement ça après ça c'était tout
le monde qu'ils avaient peur d'être
associé à moi une très peur d'être
associé à mon nom si j'ai si j'avais
quelqu'un qui me ferait de là il fallait
toujours vérifier est ce que ça va être
publicis est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
veut dire c'est comme si on n'en dort
c'est quelqu'un qui d'autre donc ça a
été très difficile mais j'aime bien
ellis clément alimentaires là c'est fini
pour vous les suppressions d'un
supplément depuis depuis que j'ai
envoyée à faire tester puis je peux vous
pouvez
j'ai pas alors qu'est ce que il faut pas
dire que c'est votre ex-conjoint les
cheveux c'est particulier de corporelle
donc c'est un homme courtage jules ccb
l'heureux mais c'était ça pour l'avenir
car ce combat on vous souhaite de vous
classer sa dent de rattraper les autres
c'était à l'entraînement c'est dans ton
de demain doit y retourner en floride
morton m'entraîner avec mes coéquipières
ça va faire du bien j'ai up puis ça va
être au quotidien et puis je pense je
vais prendre un jour par jour
m'entraîner au meilleur que ça va bien
évidemment je vais dit ce matin que je
me sens comme une flèche que ce qu'elle
avait dit oui en fait ça c'est
l'analogie que j'ai faite c'est que au
moment où tout est arrivé j'étais comme
une flèche lancée puis tout s'est
effondré au cours autour de moi donc
j'avais l'impression pu savoir si
j'avance et aussi je reculais pas je
n'avais plus de repères mais là quand
j'ai décidé de recommencer à m'entraîner
là vraiment j'ai recommencé way ciblées
alors on aimerais tu habites oiseau fait
avec vous quand vous allez faire
l'accolade à vos camarades ou lyon va
tous applaudir quand vous allez gagner
la médaille
mon objectif c'est la merci merci pour
cette vérité merci merci beaucoup